I think President Trump got exactly what
he wanted there are I would I noticed I
wrote down like not drinking out of
toilets that didn't happen including
with Russians I think we found out that
answer to that most corrupt up
presidency in history millions died due
to Trump did you reach that health care
because of health care and a few other
things the thing I picked up on
initially the first speaker Presley she
refused to talk to refer to Donald Trump
as the President of the United States
yes but only as the occupant of the
office yeah and so yeah there's not
gonna be a compromise here yeah that's
very anti feh
yeah Donald Trump won that press
conference Nancy and the squad lost that
was a terrible look it seems like they
want to victimize themselves even
further I don't think that's the way to
go against President Trump I think you
have to stand up and meet him on the
same level they're continuing to play
the victim and they're continuing to
pout and now they want to impeach him
for tweeting they're saying that he's a
white nationalist and he's you know
committing human rights violations and
deporting all these people Obama
actually deported more and also put
people in cages the point of this is
this aoc likes to talk about how much he
loves this country and they all up there
saying how much they love this country
if you want to bankrupt this country if
you want to open up all the borders if
you want to destroy the military destroy
capitalism and focus on illegal
immigrants more than American citizens
well then I think I have a different
opinion of love than she does I want to
know that definition but you won't do
that like mitla how do I follow that
Jesse Watters my god I mean let me say
this I mean this as the Democrat up here
I mean I feel for them I know that they
are incredibly passionate about a number
of the things that they said and they
they brought up some policy areas that I
think you know could actually have
legitimate dialog around that being said
they tried but I think they failed to
say that there is a theme of this is a
distraction these tweets are a
distraction and at the same time then
they circled back yes back to
impeachment and racism and all these
other issues and then what happens you
we're talking about were the minutiae of
their words and the occupant of the of
the white house and these sort of things
so if they really don't want to be a
distraction number one don't hold this
press conference and number two actually
do the work of the people I say that for
everybody Democrat Republican
independent if you're there and you are
elected to do your job do it we don't we
don't play games and if you don't want
to be a distraction mean it yeah a
couple takeaways from this all right
number one the occupant line was a
complete utter disgrace you can't on one
hand say oh this is horrible the
president has four duly elected members
of Congress to fix their countries and
then turn around and say well he's
illegitimate because he's an occupant of
the way so whatever help they thought
you you said it amazing you know they're
probably amongst ten percent of the
electorate you guys scored huge you
ladies scored huge other than that you
entirely blew it but secondly they said
well the squad is powerful um no it's
not you got exactly zero votes okay on
the green New Deal you were the only
floor to vote against this aid package
at the border and I ran for Congress and
lost and I think only got like 15,000
less votes that Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
in a d-plus 26th district right so she's
not as powerful as they think and that
press conference I think did them
absolutely no favors I think Trump comes
out of that an enormous winner occupant
in the White House is really just
disgrace we also mention the profanity
yep well I I guess I mean here's the
thing they can argue that well that's
what Trump said so I'm gonna say it okay
well yeah but he didn't say on life
telling no you said o'clock in the
afternoon
these are things that they're quoting
from other places he didn't say it on
television from Sandy this is from the
only person on the fight we ever swore
here's Trump's latest tweet I think this
happened during the thing the dams were
trying to distance themselves from the
four quote progressives but now they are
forced to embrace them that means they
are endorsing socialism hate of Israel
and the USA not good for the Democrats
exclamation points was this the plan was
this 4d chest Jesse I don't know if that
was the plan or not but that's the
result now he's got the Democrats to
circle the wagons around these four
individuals called the squad and they're
highly unpopular highly controversial
and and they're gonna fundraise like
through the roof off this thing in a way
I think I don't know this for sure
they're enjoying this moment in the
spotlight they're gonna raise their
profiles big time they're gonna run into
a strong headwind with Nancy she's not
gonna want to talk about this anymore
and then to your point earlier if this
country was really doing badly and we
were in a recession and this was the 70s
and there was lines around the block for
gasoline and we were at war and we're at
each other's throats in the streets that
would be one thing for them to call for
this impeachment of this horrible
criminal but this country is booming
right now you have the lowest black and
Hispanic unemployment we're at peace
everyone's focused on Netflix taking out
friends these are so good right now
we're worrying about a tweet yep they
should only take out a few seasons of
the office I think they are the Four
Horsemen of the the for progressive
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
for the Democrats right now in 25 years
from now this might be where America is
but hopefully not win I mean that might
be where that is not where America is
right now so I would imagine they might
fundraise off of it but the president
and the RNC is about to announce that
they raise a hundred and eight million
dollars in the second quarter of this
year money is not going to be a problem
for the Republicans in this reelection
effort at all and maybe not for the
Democrats either but money's not going
to be a problem and we're not talking
about the hilarious I mean let's think
about what the big story was coming into
this weekend
the ice raids that what happened where
did that go well nothing happened that
much yeah yeah that's why I'm sad but
I'm saying if this we're not even
talking about no else we're not talking
about we're not talking about Joe Biden
yeah that's talking about Kamala Harris
or Elizabeth Warren they'd have just
moved these frontrunners completely off
the front page and I think Biden had an
announcement about his new health care
plan today that's going nowhere your
health care you can keep your health
care he was the one Democrat that says
that but what they said though is
entirely disingenuous especially Ilhan
Omar who has spent a significant amount
of time unquestionably taking shots
people and and in the press conference
it comes out and it was nice and the
talk was lovely and she talks in these
flowery terms but that's not how she is
on Twitter anti-semitic tropes were not
living our values in the United States
that does not appeal to people in
America loves this club that Busan we're
a flawed country we're all sinners we
get it but nobody wants to hear about
how your country is crap all the time
I'm sorry but I will say this and I
don't agree with again a lot of what the
Scott stands for and I've been very
vocal about my criticism particularly of
Omar's comments on Israel and things of
that nature
but you have to admit that those women
that are standing on that stage have had
a distinctly different kind of
experience in the United States than
many of their colleagues that doesn't
make it right or wrong it makes it
different and that different experience
informs how they experience AOC I know
the area well she grew up in the issues
and she always mentions the Bronx but
she's actually the congresswoman for
Jackson Heights where my father and
grandma and my grandparents by the way
who are from an immigrant family from
Italy they owned the door up in Harlem
AOC is a sitting United States
congresswoman she is the listen
regardless of the imagery is an American
success story
Ilhan home are an even more profound
success story the story coming from them
that America is an awful place there is
a cognitive dissonance they're like are
you not getting it you're in Congress
you have power you have money you have
influence you cannot do this anywhere
else in the world great and that and
they're trying to take advantage of that
in the way that they think is best
over their heads again I'm not saying
that it's right I'm saying that that's
how they but America sucks is not a
message I'm sorry you know to your point
about Omar she says she's got this great
ear for racism she can hear it read
between the islands she hears all these
dog whistles but anti-semitism tennis
isn't every other thing so that's why I
think she's being disingenuous she picks
up every little thing in between the
lines of it's racist if it's not racist
but she goes to say it's all about the
bedroom it's what oh that's it both ways
there's a great column written by
her CLE who also was a refugee water
journal yeah thank you big reader The
Wall Street Journal as well and it goes
into that history and that background
and in particular for Omar and how it
takes a different outlook of how she was
brought up that is actually in Somalia
and she basically said how she had to
unlearn anti-semitism that was
disgusting things that were taught her
as a child right and how she feels that
some people have never unlearned that
and buy based on some of the language
used in these awful tweets speaking
about Jewish people around the world
it's gross yeah we should be able to
call it tonight that's what I talked
about the fact that like in a way there
are in a protected class in which
they're allowed to say things because
then we go but open they had a different
life experience and I you know when I
called them the snail darter z-- because
it's a small and significant group that
everybody protects yes you can you call
them that that was a great you know also
a difference to is that these women are
minorities who are being criticized but
they're not being criticized because
they're minorities and that's a big
distinction Maureen Dowd time she said
people are not disagreeing with you
because of your color they're
disagreeing with you because of your
ideas right I mean I think these were
you know white guys from Ohio as well
he's an equal opportunity guy when it
comes to filleting people he did the
wrong thing I mean you know that which
is particularly presidential yeah I mean
he wasn't xenophobic going after Cruz
for coming from Canada I don't know well
JFK you know assassin conspiracy theory
probably once but that was true